now the National Grid releases its
winter Outlook every year and it sets
out a series of demand and Supply
scenarios both gas and electricity and
in this instance there are quite a few
headlines to deal with
the first is that in order to help
manage demand the National Grid has
launched a framework scheme it's calling
the demand flexibility service which
would in essence pay consumers to reduce
their consumption at peak times so
that's things like using your washing
machine overnight charging you electric
vehicle in the middle of the day or
perhaps overnight anything to avoid
those crunch times of morning and
evening this scheme would be run via
electricity suppliers it is voluntary
and it will run from November through to
March and the reason the National Grid
is so Keen to ask consumers and
businesses to reduce demand is because
it is also saying as part of its winter
Outlook report that it is concerned in
the very worst case scenario
that Supply might not be able to meet
demand and it outlines we must stress
this is a worst case scenario
a situation like this it says in a very
very cold period of weather which is
also very still which would of course
reduce our capacity to generate wind
power when there was also problems
importing electricity from European
counterparts and a significant gas
shortage which would reduce the ability
of our gas fire power stations to make
electricity at that point there could be
planned blackouts for British households
now in a statement
spokesperson of the National Grid said
in the unlikely event we were in this
situation it would mean some customers
could be without power for predefined
periods during the day generally this is
assumed to be for three hour blocks
adding that the exact number of people
left without electricity would depend on
the extent of the gas shortages because
of course the UK gets 40 percent of its
electricity from gas-fired Power
stations now this will be a real blow to
Liz truss who has been very reluctant to
talk about individual Behavior change
and has also promised there will be no
rationing in the UK this winter and
government spokesperson said in response
to the release of these winter Outlook
reports we are confident in our plans to
protect households and businesses in the
full range of scenarios this winter in
the light of Russia's illegal war in
Ukraine and that spokesperson also
emphasized that Britain is not so
dependent on Russian energy Imports and
of course has access to domestic
suppliers from the North Sea and course
renewable energy as well but there is no
doubt about about it this warning in a
very worst case scenario of planned
blackouts for British consumers will be
alarming to many